[Música]
esta é a linguagem do dinheiro
é desta forma que a indústria financeira
tem falado conosco nas últimas décadas
embrulha os produtos financeiros em
metáforas em siglas e acrónimos repete
os ventos em conta até os tornar fatos
ninguém questiona fatos tornamos
premiava isso
esta tem sido uma ferramenta poderosa
para nos vender em o que não precisamos
é o que não compreendemos e muitas
reservas também não com custos e
comissões com dívidas e que nos fizeram
todos perder dinheiro
foi isso que nos trouxe a grande crise
financeira de 2008
dá pra cá escândalo atrás de canon um
outro manipulação de mercado ou lavagem
de dinheiro fuga ao fisco contas falsas
venda do produto especulativos
tudo isto em 2009 e 2017 fez com que o
mundial pagar as multas 345 bilhões de
dólares 345 bilhões de dólares foi o que
a indústria financeira pagou era
reguladores em multas
hoje já não lhe custos de conduta da
mesma maneira que está aí nas contas uma
fábrica para marketing e agora está em
custos de conduta é o custo fazer
negócio
deste montante só 39% foi devolvido aos
clientes
e este foi o valor que foi pago a
o restante foi recebido pelos
reguladores
por isso hoje é natural que muitos de
nós usamos eo já só quero é não perder
dinheiro eu prefiro ter o meu dinheiro
parado
o problema é que o dinheiro parado perde
o valor
o dinheiro parado não cria riqueza nos
últimos 20 anos
o euro perdeu 30% de seu valor
sai euros em 98 valem hoje 70
o dólar perdeu 35 por cento porque aqui
isto é importante
nós vivemos uma época tornos baixo as
taxas juros estão perto de zero
os depósitos a prazo vendem pouco as
obrigações pagam muito pouco é muito
importante é porque nós vivemos cada vez
mais nas últimas quatro gerações
a esperança média de vida aumentou 30
anos
temos de ter consciência vênus querer
mais para o nosso dinheiro que seria
melhor então ligar pro nosso dinheiro
não as branson social no mundo que vá
sustentar esta biografia
somos nós que temos que preparar o
futuro
somos nós que temos que nos prevenir
poupar mais começar mais cedo e investir
melhor a questão agora é como é que
fazemos em quem confiamos nessa
indústria os bancos que é confiança é
confiança é uma expectativa em
tanjiashan demora muito tempo a
construir é preciso muita coisa uma
sequência de pelo menos dez valores que
temos que ter em fazer todos os dias é
uma prestação repetido a é o clube vai
fazer confiar
há tempos a minha filha há umas semanas
mesmo que fosse com ela no dia seguinta
às compras
eu disse sim o 15º legal né
eles então mãe vamos eu deixei o novo
regulamento - mas eu já não vou
conseguir
leonor desde ok olha deixa lá por onde
eu já estava à espera
eu não costumo falhar mas facto dos
últimos tempos estava mais ocupada falei
duas outras vezes
portanto vejo que é confiança ao jogo já
estava à espera só porque aconteceu
muito recentemente o modelo às vezes é
confiança é cumprir promessas confiar em
réver que ora em cumprir as expectativas
com o psicológico aquilo que nos
prometeu por isso o que eu fiz porque
também falaram comigo as minhas
expectativas foi querer saber mais
eu também dei pra algumas festas também
perdi dinheiro nos bancos mas quis saber
mais e procurei ver o que fazem os
melhores investidores mundo
quem são os melhores e os títulos mundo
também investem dinheiro horário dose a
mais de cinco décadas
quem é em média 20% ao ano aos seus
clientes
serve claro há mais de três décadas que
ganha cerca 16% ao ano para os seus
clientes deve transcender que gere os
fundos da universidade el e ganha há
cerca de três décadas 13% ao ano para os
seus clientes que estes investidores têm
11 e fazem esses investidores têm em
comum uma filosofia de investimento que
é o investimento e valor que é o
investimento e valor é uma análise
profunda dos ativos em que temos em
investir
conhecemos muito bem o quanto valem ser
disciplinado e só comprar quando estão
baratos e aguardar o tempo necessário
até que o valor transparência até que o
ativo até que se esgotem
do ativo você investir em valor é
consistência é ter um histórico décadas
é comprovar kan com transparência como a
filosofia de investimento simples que
não se conhece a escândalos se investe
com risco o limitado
além disso que é que os investidores
tiveram em comum ao longo deste período
e os investidores investiram em ações e
este é o histórico do investimento em
ações
a linha azul mostra que ao longo dos
últimos 90 anos é classe de ativos
permitiu ter melhor rentabilidade para a
capital foram as ações e atenção durante
este período viver os momentos de grande
incerteza desde logo uma grande opção
a segunda guerra mundial várias ações
durante a crise financeira de 2008 e no
entanto as ações sempre foram elas que
deram melhor remuneração o capital muito
acima das obrigações
portanto histórico das ações comprovam
estivermos horizonte de tempo que se
pudermos em futebol o prazo são a melhor
com as tentativas
vamos focar nos meus período que todos
nós lembramos melhor
vamos olhar para que um círculo azul e
ver o que é que aconteceu neste período
entre 2007 a bola vermelha vem entre o
máximo de 2007 no mínimo de 2009 o
mercado financeiro principal impasse e
instalações do mundo queriam 55% lá pra
cá subiu 355 cento até dezembro de 2018
imagine agora que temos dois em exterior
um foi extremamente sortudo vendo o
máximo a sua carteira de ações
tudo em obrigações
o outro foi o azarado christian comprou
tudo no máximo comprou a sua carteira de
ações em máximos em 2007
vejam agora o que é que lhes acontece o
azarado via a sua a sua carteira de
ações que em 55 anos seu patrimônio e
perdeu mais de metade do seu valor e os
sortudos status cansada mentalizar cerca
de 3 3 pontos por cento ao ano e só em
2003 é que o azarado tem tanto dinheiro
como isso tudo
durante este período também se viver o
conseguir todos os dias às vezes é que
procuramos momentos de grande incerteza
no entanto é frágil o azarado que ganhou
as três vias baixos que o sortudo ganhou
e mereceu porque efetivamente teve que
se manter consistentes na sua estratégia
de investimento o que é que isto
significa
significa que é muito importante que
cada um de nós olha para trás e veja o
que é que fez mauro e no investimento o
que pode melhorar o que é cada um de nós
como tempo no erro e por melhorar para o
futuro e os ter melhor eu sugiro uma
teatro esta que ajuda a fazer da mesma
maneira quando compramos um frigorífico
somos capazes de perder três meses é um
investimento mais pequeno e muitas vezes
não fazemos queremos aplicar 50 mil
euros ou quando compramos um carro só
saná-los ponto ponto algumas coisas
importantes que reúnem para apresentar o
primeiro
qual é o objetivo do investimento é um
investimento de curto prazo
se é um investimento de curto prazo não
deve ficar em ações
as ações têm pouco risco se for
investimento a longo prazo sobre o curto
prazo são mais arriscadas por isso deve
ficar não possa prazo fica o malfadado
pode fazer falta a qualquer momento e
portanto
um deve estar em investir em ações em
quem confio
o sócio do urban challenge manga tem uma
frase que lhes só quero saber onde vou
mover para nunca lá ir
isto é extremamente importante com quem
é que estejam no passado perderam
dinheiro porque eles vão continuar a
cozinhar com as mesmas pessoas pros
ajudaram a ter uma estratégia valores
cada longo prazo porque vamos cometer os
mesmos erros confira uma pessoa vira um
histórico está aí vira um histórico do
sul para investidores a pouco tanto isto
é importante
compreendo o investimento mantenham as
coisas simples quantos quando se
quiserem entender uma coisa pra nintendo
não façam porque de certeza que está em
comissão escondidas comissões em cascata
certeza que não volta em 3 é da empresa
que está a vender isto é importante
porque se nós compreendemos bahia o
investimento não fez nós mantemos firme
nenhum que vão servindo a vossa casa do
momento para o outro alguém é por serem
ser assim
2 - 30% por ela ser dizer não eu sei que
ela vai ou mais por que é que fazem nas
ações não faz sentido
quanto custa temos o sim três aliados
com com os clientes
isto quer dizer com muitas vezes os
produtos na ces tem tantas comissões
escondidas e nunca cautela o interesse
dos clientes é fundamental ver que os
interessados tenham estejam alinhados
porque muitas vezes a comissões história
de guarda títulos de de compra e venda é
toda uma cascata de comissões que é
muito importante é a instituição
financeira ganhar mais quanto mais nós
ganharmos essa deve ser a circunstância
deve ser isso que nós preferimos
fixação adequada não víamos
diversificado mais uma carteira de 20 ou
30 empresas é suficiente
fundos de investimento têm as muitas
vezes de 300 ou 400 empresas ou
obrigações e no final ainda tem um
conjunto enorme de fundos de
investimento
a diversificação deve ser o essencial e
depois onde está o meu dinheiro quem é
que o guarda com quem é que está onde
está depositado em um banco é k era um
estrangeiro onde está o meu dinheiro
quem é que o trata o gestor do fundo que
tenham boa história poderia fazer o
mesmo é que sabem destas coisas
preocupamos com isso
isso é fundamental é importante que cada
um faça o seu trabalho porque
efetivamente vivemos a tal época todos
baixos
vivemos cada vez mais e precisamos
defender os nossos interesses
sabem o que é isto até há bem pouco
tempo eu também não sabia
hoje para mim é um símbolo de confiança
atentos
recebemos uma chamada no escritório de
alguém que cria informação para abrir
uma conta
sabes mandamos a informação toda passada
semanas só marcou reunião foi mesmo eu
crisp a pessoa na altura
verifiquei que querem visual e até o dia
da assinatura para invisuais porque o
que é que era o investimento como os
temas como é o processo mas que é
filosofia de investimento e valor e o
senhor e concordando e desvendar a
engraçada também isso no artigo assim
que a senhora escreveu chegou à final
ele disse eu quero abrir conta deixando
como compreenderá eu tenho que confirmar
pronto que segurar pronto enquanto tal
de sln detinha possui altura de se
compreender o investimento em mais do
que a senhora faz do que a maior parte
de seus clientes
em artigo que a senhora já escreveu eu
liguei pro banco tal e paciente ana para
ser essa sua empresa existe mesmo e
disseram que existe e que nunca tiveram
nenhuma informação
portanto eu quero abrir a ponta foi
nessa altura que o senhor ficou neste
aparelho para assinar este senhor tem
muitas mais dificuldades do que nós
tem muito mais barreiras de cross no
entanto foi informado foi estudar foi
aprender nunca tenha investido em ações
mas perdeu seu sentido era simples fazia
sentido
por isso todos nós e aquilo em que
acredito é que o fato confiança ganha se
com o conhecimento o conhecimento cria
competências ea competência gera
confiança
o investimento em conhecimento paga
sempre o melhor e vivendo
[Aplausos]